sounds like a spying scandal doesn't it
the warning that's the warning from uh
sir lindsey hoyle the speaker of the
house of commons and uh the a name
associated with this is the labour mp
barry gardner brent north great survivor
of labour party politics minister under
tony blair and gordon brown shadow
minister under ed miliband and jeremy
corbyn now
the spying warning from the speaker is
about a woman called christine lee
who is chinese and she has been funding
barry gardner's office including paying
for uh members of his staff who include
her son for some years now the links
between barry gardner and christine lee
have been known about for some time
papers like the times daily mail have
done stories about this what is new is
the uh
speakers very stark warning to mps
that she's involved in spying let me
read you part of a long and uh very
startling email uh sent by uh sir
lindsay two members of parliament a
similar one has gone to peers from the
lord speaker lord mcfall this is from
sir lindsay hoyle's email i'm writing
now to draw your attention to the
attached interference alert issued by
the security service mi5 about the
activities of an individual christine
lee who has been engaged in political
interference activities
on behalf of the chinese communist party
engaging with members here at parliament
and associated political entities
including the former all-party
parliamentary group chinese in britain
he goes on i should highlight the fact
that lee has facilitated financial
donations to serving and aspiring
parliamentarians on behalf of foreign
nationals based in hong kong and china
this facilitation was done covertly to
mask the origins of the payments this is
clearly
unacceptable this is clearly
unacceptable behavior and steps and
steps are being taken to ensure it
ceases well i have a statement from
barry gardner i've spoken to him in the
last few minutes he's issued a fairly
lengthy statement um
he begins by saying that this
parliamentary security director has
issued a security service interference
alert in relation to christine lee and
her attempts to engage in political
interference on behalf of the chinese
communist party mr gardner says i've
been liaising with our security services
for a number of years about christine
lee and they have always known it have
been made fully aware by me of her
engagement with my office and the
donations she made to fund researchers
in my office in the past he says steps
were taken to ensure christine lee had
no role in either the appointment or
management of those researchers they're
also aware as i have not benefited
personally from those donations in any
way she ceased funding my work any
workers in my office in june 2020. uh he
says all the donations were properly
reported in the register of mp's
interest uh source verified at the time
and he says i've been assured by the
security services that while they have
uh definitively identified improper
funding channel through christine lee
this does not to relate to any funding
received by my office uh he says
christine lee's son volunteered in my
office many years ago and was
subsequently employed by me as diary
manager he resigned for my employment
earlier today clearly related to the
speaker's warning the security services
advised me they have no intelligence
that shows he was aware of or complicit
in his mother's illegal activity he says
he'll continue to work with the security
services
and on this and all other matters
relating to security now
many conservative mps in particular
those who've clashed with the chinese
regime are pretty alarmed about all this
in the last hour
sir ian duncan smith who as he says says
one of a number of mps sanctioned by the
chinese raised this point of order in
the house of commons
i understand
that mr speaker has been contacted by
mi5 and is now warning members of
parliament that there has been a an
agent of the chinese government active
here in parliament working with another
with a member of parliament obviously to
subvert the processes here i say as a
member of parliament who's sanctioned by
the chinese government as others that
this is a matter of grave concern
well we await a further comment from sir
lindsey hoyle as to what the
parliamentary authorities what action
further action they're going to take we
also await uh uh some sort of response
from the government as well and perhaps
the security services indeed but
uh this uh looks uh like a potential
spying scandal uh barry gardner has
given his response um clearly uh
christine lee's
son
who was working for him has resigned
today so clearly uh mr gardner has taken
some action uh there are one or two
other mps who've received funding as
well uh he's the best known of these
though as i say for some years his links
with christine lee have been known uh
but this uh
this email from the speaker has shocked
many mps and there is the potential here
of a spying scandal at a very sensitive
time politically in terms of uk
relations with china